is going to be played on the 18th
fairway at the edgewood
tahoe resort golf course obviously no
fans present for those games all right
best individual games of 2020 in honor
of the very important tj oshie
anniversary best individual performances
that's our draft shireen you got a
trivia question for me i'm trying not to
look down so i see neither the question
nor the answer
adrian peterson who wants to break
emmitt smith's rushing record already
holds a record for most rushing yards in
a single game
296 versus the chargers in 200 in 2007.
whose record did he break
it was jamal lewis
you're right 295 in 2003 against the
browns very good
now who held it before jamal lewis
was it coi that i don't know did corey
dylan ever have it i remember it was
water painting for a long time
then corey dillon
thank you then jamal lewis
peterson i remember when walter payton
got 275 against the vikings back in the
70s all right first pick for me
let me guess
this one's easy christmas day red red
cleat green cleat alvin kamara six
touchdowns for the first time since
1965. nothing more to say about that one
on to the next pick
yes indeed he did get fined obviously
for those christmas shoes mike and he
got covered right after that too i'm
gonna go with derek henry in week 17
against houston he had 34 carries 250
yards two touchdowns the titans had to
win that game to get the playoffs he put
him on his back and carried him went
over 2 000 yards only the eighth running
back ever to surpass 2 000 yards
finished with 470 more than dalvin cook
a great season and a great game for
derek henry
my next win is going to be hassan
reddick because he had that huge game
uh-huh you have you should have got a
better trivia question or you'd have had
the first pick in the third pick thanks
hassan reddick with five sacks and three
forced fumbles against the giants now
was colt mccoy so and and the giants
offensive line but still hassan ready
got it done five sacks three fourths
fumbles and we're gonna have an item on
pft about how he's headed toward free
agency and there may be somebody who
offers him a significant amount of money
based upon the performance from that
game i am going to go with tyree kill
against tampa bay in week 12. how can we
forget 13 catches 269 yards three
touchdowns against carlton davis and the
chiefs apparently forgot that court
carlton davis played for the bucks
because they didn't look for him in the
super bowl but remember in that game
mike that tyree kill was on pace for
almost a thousand yards after the first
quarter he had 203 yards seven catches
two touchdowns in the first quarter just
an outstanding especially first quarter
but an outstanding game overall by tyree
kill
you know and in that game patrick
mahomes was on pace for over 700 passing
yards which would have shattered the
long-standing norm van brocklin record
from 1951 of 554 and i was it's five
four five three six i think it's 554.
i'm going to remember this one of these
days either way mahomes was on pace to
break it and another guy and mahomes
didn't he he played the second half and
obviously he didn't another guy didn't
get a chance if only the lions weren't
so bad the buccaneers wouldn't have been
blowing them out and they would have
left tom brady on the field for the
second half of that saturday game in
december when brady had for one half of
the game
348 and four touchdowns in one half you
double that you almost have 700 and you
have eight touchdowns i know it may not
have been quite as easy but he was
making it look pretty easy and i think
that's one of the that's one of the
things that that gets in the way of
somebody breaking the van brooklyn
record
unless your defense is horrible and it's
a shootout at some point you're going to
be up by so many points in the game
they're going to get you off of the
field i'm surprised mr no risk it no
biscuit didn't let brady in the state
where he went to college set the single
game record for passing yardage i really
thought we'd see him in the second half
of that game instead of blaine gabbert
but we didn't mike so he didn't get a
chance to break that record but you know
a guy who did break a record this year
and this one was really hard because
there's so many good ones left but
jeremy chen the rookie for the panthers
scored back to back defensive touchdowns
two plays in a row ran a fumble win for
18 yards for a touchdown came back on
the next play a fumble 28 yards for a
touchdown in week 12 against the vikings
he also had 13 tackles and a forced
fumble in that game just an outstanding
performance probably should have gotten
more consideration for defensive uh
player of the year rookie of the year he
didn't of course because chase young ran
away with that award but he had a great
rookie season and especially a great
game that week against the vikings
and and i remember watching that game
and and what will happen is it reminded
me of a performance from tavon austin
several years ago with the rams
where
you look up and you think oh they're
showing a a replay
of his oh no wait that's another one
that happened with three for tavon
austin in a rams game and that happened
back to back for jeremy chin and i could
have swore it was just oh that's a
replay well wait a minute something's
different about that one yeah it's a
different play it's a different drive
it's a different touchdown and the
vikings still somehow found a way to win
that game that was one of the more
exciting regular season games of the
year but that's a great one from you i'd
forgotten about that one i think i
pushed that one out of my memory great
selections one other one i had i had
jonathan taylor he had 253 yards week 15
which is when the rookies are supposed
to have hit the wall and also aaron
rodgers way back in week one in
minnesota that kind of set the tone with
four touchdown passes just shredded the
vikings defense any others on your list
that we didn't get to
yeah i had deandre hopkins catching the
the hell murray um and and that was a
huge game he had seven catches 127 yards
and a touchdown but i don't know that
they make the hill murray without him
devin white you could have picked any of
his postseason games he only played
three he missed the first one with covet
he was outstanding in all three of those
games couple interceptions and then i
had dak prescott but it came at a loss
but he passed for 502 yards against the
browns four touchdowns it ended up being
the most yards at any quarterback passed
for this season
and ben roethlisberger had over 500
yards against the browns in the playoffs
in large part because the steelers were
getting the crap kicked out of him and
they needed to throw and throw and throw
by the way the norm van broglin game 554
yards the opposing quarterbacks three of
them in the game combined for 63 passing
yards as the rams beat the new york
yanks
54-14 so they ran up the score to get
norm van broglin to 554 and that to me
is the most amazing record that has
stayed as long as it has because it
happened back in 1951.
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports